el partido gubernamental rusia unida ha
ganado las elecciones parlamentarias con
casi un 50 por ciento de los votos son
unos 5 puntos menos que en los pasados
comicios de 2016 pero con el 85% de los
votos escrutados parece que estas
elecciones parlamentarias van a dar a
putin una mayoría suficiente para poder
seguir gobernando en la duma sin
problema y eso a pesar del desgaste de
su marca electoral por culpa de los
rigores de la crisis y por la
incertidumbre que rodea al coronavirus
en segundo lugar queda el partido
comunista que es el único partido que
mejora sus resultados en estos comicios
con un 20 por ciento los comunistas son
precisamente los grandes beneficiados
del descontento de muchos rusos con la
actual situación económica los
ultranacionalistas del partido
liberal-democrático bajarían unos cuatro
puntos hasta quedarse solo con un 8% y
la sorpresa lado el partido nueva gente
un partido de nueva creación que ha sido
acusado precisamente de ser un proyecto
del crimen para captar el voto del
descontento conseguirían entrar en el
parlamento con de 17 casi en pan está
empatando con otro partido mucho más
veterano rusia justa que también
conseguiría escaños